over the course of human existence the
most significant catalyst for growth has
been our ability to draw energy from our
world
taming fire gave birth to the modern
human and drawing power from the wind
allowed early explorers to travel the
world but today we're going to explore
the history and science behind one of
humanity's greatest inventions the steam
engine the evolution of the steam engine
completely revolutionized their society
it opened new avenues for trade and cost
mass migrations of rural populations
into the newly industrialized cities
what I found most fascinating was their
lessons is evolution taught us about
science and engineering this is one of
the first practical steam engines and it
was used to pump water the engine was
incredibly inefficient this machine was
not going to start any Industrial
Revolution but had found a niche in coal
mining where its fuel was cheap and
readily available to investigate why
this engine was so inefficient let's
first talk about how it works
the engine takes energy stored in coal
and converts it to heat that heat is
used to form steam which expands into a
piston cylinder causing the pressure to
increase and forcing the piston to rise
against atmospheric pressure no
mechanical work occurs on the stroke
because this chain can only transmit
force in tension the power stroke occurs
when cold water is sprayed into the
cylinder this lower is the temperature
causing the pressure to drop atmospheric
pressure now pushes the piston back down
we want to be able to quantify how much
work is being done per cycle of this
engine to do that we plot the pressure
and volume inside the piston cylinder
for one cycle like this the area inside
is the work done but this is the
idealized PV diagram in practice there
is a lot more energy being wasted we
lose a big chunk here because the steam
is prevented from expanding to its full
volume a lot of energy is lost to the
environment too this is clearly visible
with thermal imaging the effect is made
worse by cooling the entire cylinder
with cold water so an immediate
improvement is to make a separate
condenser here the steam can be cooled
without cooling the entire cylinder
there are a lot more inefficiencies
involved that reduce the total work done
many of them are unavoidable but we can
improve the situation by upgrading the
piston cylinder
the manufacturing techniques needed to
bore accurate and strong piston
cylinders were not available in the
early days of the steam engine that
changed when John Wilkinson invented
this machine this boring machine allowed
for precise machining of solid iron
cylinders which reduced steam leakage
and made the piston cylinder stronger
thus allowing the max pressure to rise
we are starting to see a steam engine
capable of sparking an industrial
revolution but this reciprocating motion
isn't much used for most applications
especially with this flexible chain
connecting them what we need is
rotational motion which requires a
different setup to convert this linear
motion to rotational motion we need a
crankshaft and connecting rod we have
turned this piston cylinder on its side
so atmospheric pressure can no longer
force the piston back down so we need to
use steam on the return stroke this
requires a control valve to control when
the steam enters and leaves each side of
the cylinder the valve is controlled by
a cam the steam engine is now working on
both strokes of the engine improving its
efficiency and power the piston engines
like this do not produce constant torque
they'll pulsate and speed and torque
during a single cycle like this this can
cause vibrations and jerky movement we
can reduce this with the use of a
flywheel which stores rotational energy
with inertia and evens the torque out
it's essentially a mechanical battery
David Robert demonstrates this
beautifully with the v8 solenoid engine
of his own creation here you can see the
engine will continue to rotate without
additional power but the engine comes to
a dead stop without a flywheel attached
the development of steam engines thought
us a lot about thermal and mechanical
efficiencies and you may think that
steam engines have become obsolete but
nearly all of our large power stations
still use steam technology to convert
heat energy whether that be from coal
nuclear or solar to mechanical energy
the technology is simply evolved into an
even more efficient form with steam
turbines thanks for watching I have one
last device I want to include in the
development of steam engines which is
one of the most iconic inventions of the
Industrial Revolution the centrifugal
governor I'm already hearing the angry
screams in the comments section about me
using the word centrifugal so I'm going
to talk about this device in a
completely separate video to discuss the
differences between centripetal and
centrifugal force if you'd like to see
that don't forget to subscribe if you'd
like to see more content or support real
engineering the links from my patreon
Instagram Facebook and Twitter accounts
are below